comment se fait-il que l'union de la
gauche parvenu au pouvoir par la voie
des urnes avec un programme très avancé
deux ans après se retrouve sur les rails
du néolibéralisme
il faut avoir lu mon livre je le crois
qu'il est fertile en révélations de
toutes sortes pour comprendre le
mécanisme
c'est que françois mitterrand hésite
au départ parce que certains de ses
conseillers je pense à jean ribes ou le
pousse à sortir du système monétaire
européen pour donner à l'économie
française une plus grande compétitivité
mais il y à un barrage très fort de la
part de l'or et de mauroy droit le
premier ministre delors elle misé
l'économie et des finances est
finalement mitterrand trouvera pas les
hommes pour faire cette politique
bérégovoy un moment pressenti sera
écartée et françois mitterrand va mettre
le doigt dans cet engrenage qui fait que
l'année suivante jacques delors à
l'instigation d'helmut kohl devient
président de la commission européenne
avec comme mandat de faire le marché
unique c'est-à-dire de déréguler
l'économie européenne et même mondiale
c'est ce qu'on a appelé le marché unique
toutes les barrières au mouvement
non seulement de de biens et de services
mais de capitaux et de personnes vont
être supprimés c'est une grande
dérégulation près de 300 directive qui
vont être prises par la commission
européenne
très souvent de l'opacité la plus totale
à l'insu des députés français qui
entérine à l'assemblée nationale
les transpositions de directives
européennes donc on passe d'une ligne de
gauche à son contraire
alors vous appelez ça mensonge quand je
dirais changement de paradigme pour
employer l'expression d'hubert védrine
changement de paradigme
[Musique]